انضم الينا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العميد الياس حنا عميد الياس
ابدا معك بالجوزيه التي اشارت اليها
بريطانيا واستخباراتها تحديدا فيما يتعلق
باحتماليه ان تحاصر القوات الروسيه
اوكرانيا من البحر الاسود وان تنطلق من
البحر الاسود في عمليات ضد السفن المدنيه
في اوكرانيا فما مدى خطوره الوضع في البحر
الاسود في هذه المرحله
مياده هي اصلا كانت محاصره الشواطئ
الاوكرانيه ولكن اتفاق تصدير القمح هو
الذي سمح بهذا الكوريدور الاساسي اليوم
ننتقل الى مرحله جديده
ديناميكيه جديده لاول مره تقصف
الدلتا نهر الدانوب مرفع ريني على الحدود
الرومانيه وهي ايضا تقوم بمناورات بحريه
واذا نظرنا الى المياه الاقليميه للدول
بالقانون الدولي اليوم روسيه متواجده في
كل
المنطقه الاوكرانيه وحتى تقترب من المناطق
الرومانيه فاذا نحن في مرحله جديده عاده
يمرر الخبر وكانه عمليه استباق لروسيه
عمليه استباق لاي عمليه تقوم وكاننا نقول
نحملك نحملك تلك المسؤوليه خاصه ان مساعد
وزير الدفاع مساعد وزير الخارجيه الروسي
قال لن لن نقصف السفن سنصعد عليها
لتفتيشها فاذا هناك خطاب مختلف مقاربه
وكانه يريد ان يقول هذه البحيره البحر
الاسود هو بحيره روسيه بامتياز
الحصار هل هو امر ممكن عمليا وماذا عن ذاك
الممر الامن الذي تحدث عنه زيلينسكي مع
الامين العام للناتو هل ايضا بامكان
الناتو تامين ممر لنقل الحبوب
اذا كان هناك من استراتيجيه معينه حسن
بالطبع هناك ممر امن على سبيل المثال من
الدلتا يعني مرفا ومرفع اسماعيل على نهر
الدانوب الذي يصب على الحدود الرومانيه
هناك امكانيه لشحن هذه الحبوب الى رومانيا
مرفا قسطنطه ومنها على الشواطئ الاساسيه
للبلدان والتي كلها تتبع ولكن يجب ان يكون
هناك استراتيجيه معينه للنيتو تؤمن فيها
قياده وسيطره ووسائل وحتى قواعد اشتباك
ترسل الى القوات الروسيه او توجه الى
روسيا ولكن اليوم
روسيا تقصف هذه المرافع هذه الدلتا وهناك
جسر يصل هذه المنطقه
ضرب ايضا وكانها تقول ليس هناك من اي
امكانيه الا عبر البر لشرق اوروبا وهذا
امر يخلق منافسه للحبوب مع بولندا مع
رومانيا مع الدول وهذا يشكل عائق
للاتحاد الاوروبي طيب اليوم العنوان
العريض الذي يعتمده الجانبان الاوكراني
والروسي فيما يتعلق بالسفن في البحر
الاسود هو انها قد تكون محمله باسلحه
وبالتالي تكون هدفا مشروعا للطرفين ما
اشرت اليه قبل قليل حول حديث وزير
الخارجيه الروسي حول الانزال وليس
الاستهداف اشارت ايضا اليه المخابرات
البريطانيه فيما ذكرته لك بان السفينه
المسمى
قد تستخدم لمهام اعتراض في البحر الاسود
طبيعه هذه السفينه ما الذي يمكن ان يقوم
به الاسطول الروسي عبر هذه السفينه
اولا سفينه سريعه سفينه تعترض سفينه مسلحه
لديها كل الاجهزه ولديها قدره على الانزال
ان كان عبر البحر او ان كان عبر الطوافه
على السفينه لتفتيشها ولكن مياده لنكن
واقعيين يعني اليوم هل تحتاج اوكرانيا
السفن لتهريب الاسلحه عبر بحر تسيطر عليه
روسيه والطرق من بولندا ومن رومانيا ومن
كل الدول التابعه للحلف الناتو هي مفتوحه
لجر هذه الاسلحه لا اعتقد اليوم هناك
الحجج الاساسيه ولكن اذا عدنا الى القانون
الدولي او اتفاق البحار يؤنقله او
المعاهده الكبيره اليوم اوكرانيا لديها
الحق ولكن بين الحق شيء وبين الامر الواقع
شيء اخر شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه العميد الياس حنا